welcome back to our turkey teson before
the break Michelle from Charlotte North
Carolina asked if um her boyfriend could
impress her family on Thanksgiving like
dos and don'ts you want to bring a gift
bring an appropriate gift oh yeah
something like a gravy
boat a nice gravy boat yeah that that'll
work that'll work and then you also want
to game plan with your significant other
before so that they understand the
family Dynamics they know who who is
going to talk their ear off who's going
to have a little too much to drink all
of that and then just follow their lead
and kind of go with the flow when you're
there and of course of course you want
to offer to clean up right yeah oh like
do the dishes after we're finished yes
honey at least dry the dishes just offer
yeah yeah you don't have to do it what
about this scenario let's say that
Andrew and Drew are a boyfriend
girlfriend okay and they're at dinner at
think family Thanksgiving dinner and
they're getting really about the fact
that we were brother and sister just a
minute this is a fresh new scene okay
new scene new scene so they're boyfriend
girlfriend they're at the Thanksgiving
family dinner table and they they start
look putting the PDA on and it's getting
kind of like hot and oh my God my
goodness those cream things man they
really just get me excited W let's have
another oh no you got a real nice house
Mrs
bear so
what's
appropriate what's not and how do we all
handle that most action that what feels
like to kiss is that right wait more
please sorry go on I say the the second
one was appropriate the first one with
the green bean maybe that's a step too
far what do you think sah
Jane Sarah Jane's never speaking to us
again um so in PDA like 1 second is
equivalent to a minute oh yeah so keep
it short you also have to see like what
are their parents like if their parents
are really PDA then okay you can get
away with a little PDA but if the
parents don't do any PDA and you're
there like doing what you just
did then you might want to
reconsider a second is a minute at PDA
that really Sarah once again you've
changed my brain anatomy
you just got to get you some PDA now I
know and also I'd like you to keep your
hands up on the table okay for the rest
of it it's dinner okay up here hands up
hands up okay damona Sarah here's
another question what if you're meeting
your partner's family for the first time
and you don't want to try their family's
secret recipe you know like it's just
not for you what do you recommend I'd
say you could have a few bites you know
just to be polite right okay maybe you
agree I agree I mean you can't not try
it um yes you can you got to tell them
you have an allergy I'm not touching
that yes that is actually so M that's
actually that that that's a good little
trick to say you're allergic otherwise
put on your plate have a small bite and
then cover it with something else like
this oh oh this is good anything was
under here I have something like Drew
for example she doesn't like you you you
don't like goat cheese and you don't
like truffle right no I will not eat
either of them so like if you were at my
Thanksgiving and I had my family's
favorite goat cheese truffle crustini
right here and I said here you go you're
a fancy family what would you do bite
just a
bite accidentally drop
it have a bite and cover it are you
going to do it babe don't do it
babe There You Go problem
you're a genius we really did
that what do you do what do you
[Applause]
do oh my
God so have she sah this
Thanksgiving why do people like
that Sarah did she do well yeah yeah
Drew remembered my etiquette lost you
yeah yeah Thanksgiving is wild that
you're
house are you feeling more optimistic
about yours yeah I think I'm going to
ace mine if this is the bar I'm
[Music]
solid